welcome back to las vegas now our real
estate expert harvey blankfeld is back
to give us an update on this crazy las
vegas housing market hey harvey hey
rocky thanks for having me back of
course always good to hear from you and
get an update on what's going on it's
interesting our real estate market
continues to go away from sellers it's
still very much a seller's market but
the inventory continues to creep up
which means it's going to head more
towards a balanced market and i got to
say bringing me on after david from
magic mike was smart because if you
brought me on
before he would never would have been
able to shine like he did oh i mean
they should bring you up on stage right
absolutely yeah no i'm going to i'm
going to call in and see what you can do
all right so we want to talk
specifically about eye buyers today what
does that mean yeah i buyers are the if
you've seen the commercials on
television from the companies that are
offering to pay cash for your home make
it a very convenient process uh i i've
seen the one commercial where the ladies
goes oh what kind of and she pushes the
button and apparently it's done i don't
know if that's the way it works or not
but nonetheless the thing i want to
caution all of your viewers about is
when you're considering selling your
home always consult your trusted
professional go to the realtor you know
if you don't know what call me i'll be
happy to help you i have actually in the
course of investigating offers that some
of my clients have received from some of
these companies these big corporations
i've actually advised them to take it
and and because for their purpose it was
right it's you're trading convenience
for price as long as you're not as
concerned about how much money you get
at closing
it may be a good option for you because
it is convenient now having said that
make sure you read the fine print
because there's always some catches to
their offers of course but that's also
why we have to work with you yeah thank
you so what are the things that we have
to look out for in these situations what
should we you know be aware of they like
to use they like to say hey no
commissions they use that term but then
they charge you fees which usually
amount to as much or maybe even more
than the commissions the other thing
that some often times happens is after
they put you under contract they go in
and look at the house and then they give
you a list of items that need to be
repaired
on your dime for them to be able to
resell your home later now you know
these companies aren't buying the home
to live in it right they're buying it to
flip it they're buying it to sell it and
make a profit and so when you sell it to
them you're selling wholesale when you
sell it through a realtor to another
individual buyer you're selling what i
consider retail you're getting a better
best price okay let's get into some
examples what what's an example of a
time where someone should go ahead
and do the ibuyer if you are pressed for
time you have to be out of the house by
a certain time and you need the money in
your bank
and you're not as concerned about the
money you're not as concerned hey i
don't i don't need a real big check i
just need a check quick okay that's when
you should consider those three people
now also if you contacted me or your
trusted advisor we can often get you
bids from them but not just one of them
maybe let them compete against one one
another still get you the biggest
possible price oh real estate's such a
game such a game thank you so much
harvey uh thank you to real estate real
est las vegas real estate now excuse me
for sponsoring this segment for more
information just call 702 203 1165 or
find them online at
lvrealestateradio.com always a pleasure